your co-star and you Ilana Glazer you've
been together how many years working as
kind of an you start as an improv team
yeah we were the only two women on the
improv team in 2007 Wow yeah we did the
[Applause]
yeah we we did that we're on this team
called secret promise circle mm-hmm
brilliant name we came out of UCB The
Upright Citizens Brigade it was terrific
yeah and yeah we did improv in lots of
grimy basements in New York City we paid
to do it
like we paid it costs us a lot of money
we would provide shots for everybody
you're talk about the early years you
really have to I remember when I first
came out here to LA and I was working in
the day as a writer on TV show but at
night I would go and I would you know do
weird improv shows and different people
like you know Lisa Kudrow was an improv
group just me and we would do them in
basements nobody would come nobody would
play you know theater improv games and
there'd be like one wino in the audience
yeah like six people was like an amazing
turnout right incredible turnout we're
your parents supportive during this time
that's the key question what did they
have faith in you that you're gonna make
it um I think there were some like
behind the scenes convos I wasn't a part
of yeah definitely like at home but they
were very supportive at both Alana and
my parents were very supportive they
came to a couple of these shows which
was so sad you know like you're I'm like
I'm in the big city
performing come right and and they're
like half of the audience
yeah that's upsetting but so we started
doing bread City as a web series called
broad city and we did that for two years
and we kind of really did it to be able
to send our parents a link and be like
we're actually doing it this is a
product it's out there
did it work I mean your parents what
they would see one what YouTube what
were they see one yeah and my mom I
remember she she would tell people she
was like my daughter is on YouTube
[Laughter]
YouTube and I was like you are probably
on YouTube yeah
you